لو احصينا عدد الكاميرات هنا واحده اثنتين
ثلاثا هناك عشر كاميرات
زي ما انت شايف الضغط علينا من كل الشيكات
المستوطنين من شقه والكاميرات من شقه
يعني وين ما اروح في تل الرميده
بنحس حالنا مراقبين دائما مراقبين وين
مكان
هاي مش حياه ولا عيشه
[موسيقى]
وايها بتوين اسرائيل لدينا اثنتان وعشرون
نقطه تفتيش اسرائيليه مثل هذه ما يجب ان
نعرفه ان هذا الحاجز يتعرف علي حتى قبل
وصول اليه احيانا يقول لي الجندي اعطني
بطاقتك الشخصيه يا عزت هو يعرف اسمي
انشا الذكاء الاصطناعي ما يشبه السجن
الرقميه في الخليل مؤخرا قام جيش الاحتلال
بتثبيت هذا السلاح الالي والذي يسمى مطلق
النار الذكي
الرابط بين هذه الانظمه
وهي قاعده بيانات تهدف الى بناء ملف شخصي
كامل لكل فلسطيني في الضفه الغربيه بدءا
باسمه ومكان اقامته وافراد اسرته وصولا
الى لوحات وتراخيص السيارات وغيرها وما
اذا كان مطلوبا ام لا
لقد ارسل صندوق اسرائيل الواحده مؤخرا
طائرات درون مزوده بكاميرات تعمل بالاشعه
تحت الحمراء ليستخدمها المستوطنون في
مراقبه القرى الفلسطينيه وهناك تقارير عن
مستوطنين يستعملونها لملاحقه المزارعين
عندما يسوقون مواشيهم للرعي في الحقول
ويقومون باخافتها
مؤخرا باع صندوق اسرائيل الواحده كاميرات
للمستوطنين قاموا بتثبيتها عند التقاطعات
المزدحمه عبر الضفه الغربيه هذا يبين مدى
قدره المستوطنات على نصب الكاميرات خارج
نطاق سلطتها
[موسيقى]
انه شكل جديد من اشكال الفصل العنصري لكن
بشكل فعال وغير مرئي
[موسيقى]